what's your take canelo and this whole
uh jake paul and everything that's going
on who's he fighting jake paul
jake paul is fighting ben askren you
know ben askren he's a fighter he's an
mma fighter
they've been killed
ben ascher he's a two-time ncaa champion
he was actually my olympic teammate in
2008
he fought he's a ufc fighter but he
didn't go so well for him but he's also
a troll
a guy likes to go on the internet and
talk about [ __ ]
so jake so is jake paul but the thing is
is like it's different because this ben
ashton guy
he can't grapple and boxing doesn't
matter who you are because
you box it's different it's completely
different listen
what's so interesting about boxing like
if you make that guy's got better hands
you can grab him yeah
if you're boxing the guy's really better
head you got to do a lot of things
it'll be a long night yeah you know you
throw faster you harder
you're like [ __ ] he's smart hard to hit
he had
some thinking yeah and i i think i feel
like i've noticed something in boxing
too that
mma guys don't bring and you guys have a
certain pressure
when you fight an mma guy and you fight
a boxer they're very composed and they
stalk you
like well you're like afraid because you
don't know what's coming because mma you
got legs on the elbows and stuff
boxing just like this yeah so you have
which makes it a whole lot more
difficult but to get back to that what's
your take on
on jake paul and the things that are
going on in boxing right now do you
think that's good for boxing or what's
your take on that
[Music]
anybody can do whatever it is that they
want to desire but he says boxing's no
joke i mean nate robinson he said he had
no
he had no reason to become a
professional boxer
i mean look at him he says they made him
they left him half dead after that fight
i mean this is this isn't a joke either
listen
um imagine how he feels really he comes
outside the [ __ ]
you talk about uh robinson yeah and he
was on he was on your undercard mic
yeah deal with it because i got
gotta deal with that [ __ ] with family
and kids
you